et la gestion de l'épidémie en france
scrutées de près la commission d'
enquête parlementaire de l'assemblée
nationale commence ses travaux ses après
midi cet après midi elle débute à 17h
avec l'audition de jérôme salomon le
directeur général de la santé celui qui
a été le visage de la crise avec son
point-presse quotidien sera interrogé
sur le retard pris en février sur la
pénurie de masques sur la fluctuation
nos doctrines les concernant sur le
manque aussi de test ou encore sur les
nombreux décès survenus en ehpad
il sera suivi ces prochains jours des
experts de santé défileront aussi devant
l'élégant devant les députés
les anciens ministres de la santé et les
responsables politiques après le second
tour des municipales
pour en parler nous retrouvons jean
françois corty de médecins du centre un
collier de la rochefoucauld à paris
le généraliste bonjour et merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france qu'est
ce que vous attendez de cette enquête
parlementaire
je crois que ce qui est important c'est
de ces deux pouvoirs deux choses
remettre en lumière ce que la crise a
révélé en termes d'un préparation des
autorités françaises mais la majorité
des dpi dans le monde la préparation
vis-à-vis de cette épidémie
et puis au pouvoir aussi rediscuter
d'une communication assez douteuse des
autorités qui ont du mal
justement a affirmé au départ de la
crise le manque de masse de test et donc
être dans un pseudo mensonges et prendre
un peu la société civile en défaut et
puis c'est aussi l'occasion évidemment
de pouvoir réaffirmé la nécessité
d'améliorer notre système de santé de
lutter contre les inégalités ce que les
soignants revendique aujourd'hui que
vous avez traité dans le sujet précédent
c'est l'occasion de pouvoir réaffirmé un
état social fort démocratie n'assiste
sanitaires nécessaires
un certain nombre de responsables vont
donc défiler ces prochaines semaines
devant les députés des responsables
administratifs des externe centaine de
responsables politiques des anciens
ministres de la santé jusqu où est-ce
qu'il faut remonter dans le temps selon
vous pour déterminer les chaînes de
responsabilités et à qui la faute dans
l'impréparation de la situation que nous
venons de vivre préparation elles datent
pas de gouvernants actuels et les plus
anciennes avec une perte de capacité
d'auto suffisance des autorités
françaises avec une logique finalement
politique a plutôt fondé sa stratégie
sur des économies en matière notamment
de santé puisque on a supprimé une bonne
partie des stocks de masques on a perdu
nos capacités de production notamment
deux tests cette logique on va dire
financière absolue aux dépens de la
santé aux dépens la capacité de notre
état à pouvoir défendre l'intérêt
citoyen c'est logique talent s'affirme
depuis longtemps il va falloir inverser
la tendance et puis il va falloir
réaffirmé que pour avoir un système de
santé solidaire pour faire permettre une
érable soit pris en charge
eh bien il va falloir des mois il est un
des moyens conséquents payer davantage
de et soyons plus dans bones et ça fait
quelque chose qui va falloir apporter
plus long terme pour éviter qu'une telle
crise sanitaire ne se reproduise il
faudra aussi retrouver notre
indépendance notre souveraineté dans
plusieurs domaines concernant notamment
les équipements médicaux
oui on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
évidemment dans le monde globalisé c'est
difficile d'avoir une stratégie
d'autosuffisance parce que notamment sur
les médicaments même sur la capacité de
les produire pour la plupart en france
on dépend quand même ce qu'on appelle
les matières premières des principes
actifs qu'il faut obtenir à
l'international et qu'il va falloir des
priorités et prioriser donc sur des
choix stratégiques d'autosuffisance et
je pense notamment à l'accès à la
nourriture l'accès à l'eau l'accès à
l'énergie l'accès aux soins en
respectant aussi des critères de
sécurité
et ça ce sont des choses fondamentales
il faut mettre avant ça veut dire des
moyens ça veut dire un état social fort
dans une démocratie sanitaire forte ça
veut dire accepter l'idée qu'un certain
ultralibéral jusqu'à présent a été assez
marqués soit mis de côté au profit d'une
approche beaucoup plus
n de la santé publique notamment à
l'italie l'espagne le royaume-uni on le
voit en partout dans le monde les
gouvernements sont pointés du doigt pour
leur gestion de la crise est ce qu'on
aurait vraiment pu être préparé à une
telle crise oui je pense que depuis de
nombreuses années des alertes
interviennent de la part de chercheurs
en médecine en sciences sociales on sait
qu'avec la clé l'accentuation de la
crise climatique notamment avec eux nos
modes de voyage et d'interconnexion
important avec une augmentation des
grosses villes qui vont pénétrer dans
les forêts ou des maladies qui vont de
l'animal à l'homme sont de plus en plus
fréquent qu'on sait et on savait qu'il y
avait des risques notamment en matière
des maladies émergentes telles que celle
qu'on a vécue aujourd'hui avec des morts
potentiel à plusieurs plusieurs
anticipations a été fait sauf que nos
acteurs politiques depuis de nombreuses
années encore une fois ont préféré
mettre de côté une politique fondée sur
la préservation de la vie humaine mettre
de côté une approche de prévention et on
a payé cash
lors de cette crise la capacité de
pouvoir notamment l'hôpital plus de lits
de réanimation mais la capacité d'avoir
aussi une médecine de proximité des
équipes qui a re pouvez aller sur le
terrain pour faire des tests pour isoler
les malades pour soignants auximines tu
es donc seriez l'épidémie on a manqué de
cette capacité de prévention et c'est
aussi ce genre de stratégie qui va
falloir réinventer pour pouvoir se
protéger à l'avenir de ces maladies
émergentes
merci beaucoup jean françois corty je
rappelle que vous êtes notamment
médecins du centre un colis de la
rochefoucauld cet appareil